never take a chance never piss off your
tattoo artist
[Music]
what makes a tattoo fun to work on
artistic freedom
is what makes it fun the more freedom i
have
the more fun it is i like anime and
animal portraits it really makes me
happy to work on
what are common mistakes some tattoo
artists make
people may misunderstand what customers
like about the colors
or yeah the shading maybe the common
mistakes tattoo artists make are more on
the artistic side
than the technical making it look real
and look solid
but every artist makes mistakes it's a
matter of how well they hide them
lettering mistakes are a horrible
experience early in my career i made a
couple and
ever since then i'm a lot more careful
about making sure everything's spilled
right
what do you do when someone doesn't like
a tattoo after it's finished well that's
simple you club them with a baseball bat
and drag them out in the back so no one
finds them
there's one customer maybe the first or
second year i
start tattooing he was just mentioned
like he wants a line and geometry and
that's it
and he said oh you can design whatever
you want and he said oh i like it blah
blah blah
and a week later he sent me an email and
he's like oh this is not what
exactly i want you have to fix it i'm
like
dude it's a wrap around arm if you want
to fix it
you might be just remove your skin or
get some like lasers or something
because
it's not my mistake once you're a
seasoned artist you know how to make it
clear as to what they're
going to expect have i ever laughed at
anyone in pain
absolutely after getting my head
tattooed nine hours and a concussion
i don't really feel pain much anymore
after that experience
so when someone's in pain i kind of
chuckle and
my bedside manner is not the greatest so
the more pain you're in the more i kind
of laugh at you
maybe i'm laughing with you not at you
there's a mother
her daughter also came together with her
and she just want a tiny
fatty boop and she's like oh my god what
i'm doing
oh my god oh i cannot oh like i'm i'm
like okay
so it's gonna just be like 10 minutes
work and
you gave a birth to a daughter so it's
maybe the most painful level not left
but
yeah i laughing inside of me have i ever
tattooed someone's genitals
uh plenty uh mostly females i don't know
how to say i'm like
what the i come at your dick with a
needle
an erection is the last thing that's
gonna happen if anything it's gonna be
like a turtle popping his head back in
the shell
so you gotta kind of yank it pull it
over your finger and pull it tight and
do the tattoo all right for me it's
gross
who are the worst customers well believe
it or not i tattoo a lot of tattoo
artists and they are definitely the
worst customers
they tend to want to help you so they're
moving their body thinking they're
getting in the right position and all it
is doing is annoying you
you just need them to sit still and
behave preferably shut up half the time
and just endure it i hate people like
keep screaming and
talking really loudly if you think you
cannot do with the pain just don't do it
what's the best way to negotiate crisis
we may ask clients what's your budget
and if it's close to our original price
we can do that and we can just price
down
for your piece and but if it's too big
difference
we may ask you to find another shop or
some saving and come back trying to
negotiate down and haggle down the price
is just going to leave a bad taste in
the tattooers mouth
and you may not get the 100 quality work
that you're hoping for
never take a chance never piss off your
tattoo artist
what tattoos do i get nervous about
giving uh
i don't get nervous you can't get
nervous there's no room for nervous
tattooing requires a great degree of
confidence so if you're nervous for a
tattoo as an artist
uh you're probably not performing at top
notch
tattoos you should not get significant
others your boyfriend your girlfriend
it's a jinx man it's job security for us
to fix that
every day another one would be logos i
don't know it makes you a billboard it
seems kind of lame to me
unfortunately in tattooing there are
trends like tribal was a trend for a
while
spent years fixing that crap after it
wasn't a trend anymore what part of the
body
is the most painful stomach the ribs the
feet
the hands the lower spine the butt
on the knees close to the bone back of
like
the arm here it all hurts it's an
annoying pain and you just gotta
deal with it you know as far as where it
hurts the least
well that's probably on someone else
thank you for watching and i hope you
get information from
get tattoo and you can search us like
whistle tattoo
in brooklyn and i hope to see you in the
future well i hope i was able to answer
some of your questions today
if you're ever in midtown new york city
come look me up
full booth
[Music]
you